this is dark matter no not the actual
dark stuff the little green lines and
this is a black hole or at least it's a
simulation of one see the blue region
around the black hole that's called the
ergo sphere a spinning gravitational
field so powerful it can suck these
elusive dark matter particles into its
gyre what's the point the ergosphere is
like a gigantic particle accelerator see
those glowing dots gamma rays which is
what dark matter particles become when
they smash together and convert their
mass into energy
thanks Einstein they only show up on the
left hand side because the air goes here
spent so powerfully it pulls the fabric
of space-time along with it in other
words it's theoretically impossible for
a particle to move the other way let's
go back to the beginning I never get
tired of that swirling even though
nobody knows much about dark matter it's
essential to our understanding universe
simply because there's so much of it
like 75% of the universe is dark matter
in order to confirm these simulations
NASA we need to train telescopes on
black holes more than a million times
more massive than our own Sun but the
hard part telling which gamma rays come
from that black hole and which are from
the billion of their gamma-ray sources
in the universe good luck NASA